chaque jour a dit jean ouverture du
procès de jean marie villemin neuf ans
après le meurtre de son fils le petit
grégory en fait jean marie villemin est
jugé pour l'assassinât de son cousin
bernard laroche qu'il tenait pour le
meurtrier mais dès le premier jour du
procès on a vu que c'est toute la sphère
grégory qui était évoquée au tribunal
dominique verdeilhan
jean marie villemin séparé de la salle
d'audience par une vitre mesures de
protection précise-t-on à dijon et pour
la première fois cet après midi jean
marie villemin va s'adresser aux jurés
je n'attends qu'une chose que muriel
dise la vérité sur la mort de mon enfant
jean marie villemin n'a aucun regard
pour le banc de la partie civile l'a
pourtant où sont assis entre autres
marie ange laroche la veuve de bernard
et surtout muriel bolle une présence que
les avocats de jean-marie villemin
qualifie d' inconcevable pour eux muriel
n'a pas sa place sur le banc des
victimes à dijon elle ne doit être que
témoin parce que principal témoin à
charge pour son beau frère bernard
laroche l'a utilisé de façon cynique
muriel a été son instrument plaide m e
thierry moser elle ne doit pas assisté
au procès avant de témoigner nous ne
voulons pas d'un témoignage sous
influence enchaîne m chastan muriel et
bernard laroche ont été les deux
dernières personnes à voir grégory
vivant conclut m garot en face la partie
civile n'a évidemment pas la même
lecture du dossier laroche coupable ce
ne sont que des hypothèses bernard
laroche n'a pas été jugé par l'arrêt de
non lieu de christine villemin insiste m
teissonnière la cour a décidé muriel
reste partie civile et donc pour
assister à la totalité des débats le
procès de la dernière chance que
commencer